this is from joe.co.uk
Chinese whistleblower claims first covet
outbreak was intentional and I can
believe it this is a guy who defected I
think it was something like a couple
decades ago 1987. he was held in prisons
because he has been fighting for
democracy but apparently he still has
individual he still knows he still has
sources and they provided him provided
him information that said that in 2019
at the world military games China
released a virus now that's his claim
where were the world military games in
September 2019 they were in Johan at
Ninth and there were nine thousand
athletes many of whom were sick with
some pneumonia-like disease I've had
I've actually had members of that reach
reach out to me afterwards or family
members and say Hey you know my you know
not going to say which family member was
but someone I was related to was on that
trip they came back they were sick we
got sick we passed that along we have no
idea what that was and it's been so long
now that we can't you know really get
tested for it so we're not sure what
happened but a lot of people were saying
the symptoms were very
covered like so I'll say this I don't
know about intentionally I think when
you look at the lab leak evidence you
would be insane not to conclude this
leak from a lab whether it was you know
if it was intentionally done that's
something totally different but we
actually have a director claims that he
went in November or I'm sorry uh yes in
November he went to U.S intelligence and
said this thing that just happened
this wasn't an intentional release of a
virus and the funny thing is
we we have the benefit of hindsight
we can look back at these past couple of
years and be like why didn't they listen
well think about it the world military
games happens and some people got sick
so what so you got a bunch of athletes
who get sick and then you don't even
notice because not not that many get
sick and then some guy comes to you and
says people got sick because China
intentionally released a virus they're
going to be like what are you talking
about and especially the game turn off
without a hitch especially if they use
the phrase you know if they say oh it's
a bio weapon secret Chinese project
military it just it kind of fits that
sort of thing where and you know saying
this for someone who's in the Intel
Community
um you you get a lot of walk-ins right
you get a lot of walk-ins you get people
coming all the time with this story that
story and because of the Iraq wmd
scenario because of that situation
anything that kind of falls into that
bucket of uh NBC not NBC the company but
uh nuclear biological chemical there's
always there always is a little bit of
hesitancy from people in the community
because of that experience to really
jump on one of those things and there's
hesitancy from people that you know your
middle managers Etc to pass that on to
the higher drops the generals or the
dazdies or certainly anyone in the White
House give it to the president just
because of that situation because you
don't want to be the next Colin Powell
that you know Etc
were this like I'm curious was uh was
kovid more negatively impacting Asian
people was it wasn't there something
about like people who had uh some people
had more ace2 receptors based on their
Heritage yeah I thought it was Asian men
no I thought Asian men were less likely
I don't know I don't remember
yeah because I remember seeing something
about
um less ace2 receptors based on you know
different parts of the world and stuff
like that so I'd be curious
um I could I could be wrong about this I
don't know do you see anything uh Ian
no uh is this here from e-turbo news
that says East Asians and men have more
than say white Europeans Okay small
receptors which means they're more
susceptible that's just according to
this I don't know but that's so
unconfirmed so so regardless of the
outcome I think it's interesting China's
accused the U.S of releasing this but it
was a joint Chinese China and U.S
research there's joint China U.S
research being done at the one Institute
of virology so I mean I don't I don't
know man
this also says that men have more than
women
by Nature
lungs yeah yeah so what do you think do
you believe this guy
I don't know I don't know for sure but I
do know just from an analysis standpoint
I could certainly see a scenario where
someone and not necessarily Xi Jinping
but somebody in China says hey we have
this situation on our hands it looks
like this thing is breaking out why
should we be the only ones who have to
take a hit on this why should we be the
only ones who have to take the economic
hit the supply chain hit the monetary
hit they're going through a monetary
situation right now with evergrand
um yeah breaking out so why not
why not just let it ride the intentional
thing I'm not sure there's enough
evidence of but a lab leak right a lab
leak but
a lab leak that you don't respond to
immediately right or
look what happened with Fukushima like
you think you can cover it up yeah yeah
there's like just just just get rid of
it quickly and don't have to admit
anything but but you know I guess the
challenge is they didn't shut down
travel 2-1 they allowed outbound travel
didn't they they did yeah so it doesn't
sound like they were trying to uh it
sounded like they were like you know
what it hit us it's gonna hit everybody
else so when when Chernobyl happened and
um one thing that HBO totally missed in
the Chernobyl mini series I think is
quite good but one thing that and my
wife coming from having been in the
Soviet Union
um always points out that that they
totally missed is that if you look at
the dates Chernobyl happens in late
April what is May 1st right May 1st is
May Day right in the Soviet Union this
is a huge day of Celebration it's
parades people are outside people are
you know garlands of flowers etc etc so
all of that happens in the Chernobyl
area and across Belarus where um a lot
of the winds were blowing it so be so
this Fallout they allowed that to go on
even though they knew the Meltdown had
occurred wow because they didn't want to
admit it to the West yep and I think it
was only because they detected radiation
in Sweden or something right that anyone
started to realize what was going on
with Chernobyl because people in Sweden
started getting sick and people you know
they started detecting things what's
going on hey Russia or hey Soviet Union
do something you like to tell us yeah
right and so what's amazing though is
because we have this situation now where
what's the difference between the U.S
relationship with China than the CCP
versus the US relationship in the USSR
there is a monetary financial and a deep
economic relationship between the US and
China that the US and the Soviet Union
never had our Elites are getting rich
off of this supply chain off of the
exploitation of cheap Chinese labor the
weakers ETC everything else you don't
have that now so you don't have this
huge car look at all the movies the
cultural John Cena attack John Cena
going out and speaking really really bad
Mandarin
apologizing
Taiwan Taiwan
foreign
which is why they mock them because they
know they're lesser it's crazy isn't it
but so so I mean this is white left by
the way right so this is the situation
and then they
because we are and like our Elites are
so in bed with them
you don't have that situation like like
Moscow do you want to tell us something
Beijing do you want to tell us something
I'm sure behind the scenes you know
there's quite a bit but then a lot of
this was kept and Peter Navarro has a
book coming out I think his book could
just hit number three on Amazon where he
was talking about having been in the
room with fauci
um because keep in mind fauci obviously
knows about all this stuff or has the
ability to pick up the phone and say hey
did we you know something going on over
Wuhan where's that guy where's that
Peter guy you know did he have something
going on with with this does he know
what's happening and you know we talked
to her about Peter Napier Navarro and
and Navarro says that moment never
happened right you'd think like if it's
seen in a movie right you think the
scientist would come in oh my gosh Wuhan
that's where the lab is that's where we
were doing the funding what's what's
happening and then like Jeff Goldblum
runs rushes in I told you I told you it
would be considered bad writing yeah it
would be like the scientist runs in and
goes ladies and gentlemen a virus has
broken out in a city with a virus gain
of function research lab and people
watching it go
where's the farming Village and then
like the peasants gets sick
you're getting the soup and then it gets
to what's in in uh an outbreak I think
it's the the bat you know and then bite
somebody and then they go to a casino
and Macau and there's like some
Americans there and like but but you
know if they were making a movie about
this it would literally be like a guy
working in the research you know wearing
in the original July wearing the suit
and then he would be like handling a bat
and it would bite his finger exactly
yeah
Peter Parker look around and be like
nobody saw and then you go out and wash
and be like I have a stand well one
thing after some coughing later one one
thing that also one thing also that I
think people should consider is that
even though they always say there's no
evidence of of
um bats being sold at this wet Market uh
keep in mind though that the standards
for control over these type of things in
China are just not that big so there are
also economic incentives that hey if
you're somebody that maybe just works
you're a worker there you're a janitor
or something and you see hey there's a
couple of bats it looks like the
experiment's over they won't miss one
they won't miss two or maybe you know
you're selling them off the back of the
truck to a guy and then he goes and
takes them out into the city it doesn't
have to be at the wet Market to be some
guy he knows and maybe he's been doing
this for a while and has no idea right
yeah so again right there there are so
many permutations you could think of to
create a lab leak theory that all of
which are very valid and if I wanted to
go uh you know if we were trying to go
from like the most plausible scenario
like research was being done and then
there was a lab leak because of you know
incompetence to the most and completely
implausible one I would love to just you
know theorize about Xi Jinping trying to
gain the ability to control bats and
wield them like some kind of villain
he's doing that then but then the bats
you know break out of control and they
were trying to use a virus to control
their minds and then I'll hell breaks it
seems like more of a Kim Jong-un thing
yeah I can see Kim Jong-un being into
that what you're saying is Navarro was
in the room when fauci learned about it
but he didn't react no no well basically
yes and so you would expect so Navara
scientists to be like oh my gosh let's
look in but because he didn't react it
was kind of like why didn't he react to
that right so then eventually it becomes
like the political appointees in the
administration and this is what
Navarro's book is entirely about and
he's been he's actually calling me like
a minute ago
um that you know he's just he's trying
to tell people the story of what
actually happened to say hey we found
out all this stuff about Wuhan and then
we see fauci's name on it we see NIH and
niaid we said excuse me are we funding
this stuff Tony what's what's going on
here man like what's just you know we're
trying to fight this thing we don't want
people to be getting sick do you know
something that you'd like to tell us
because keep in mind that when you go
back and watch those old videos of fauci
where he's talking about the need for
gain of function research what does he
say he says we need to do this because
if there is a zoonotic spillover event
we need to be prepared for it we need to
have
um elements on the shelf or resources or
at least just the knowledge like total
bull crap to be able to prepare for
something so but just go with me on this
right so it's like okay let's take out
your word if that's the case
why didn't you have that moment of
saying oh my gosh they were studying
something just like this hold on let me
call up sure Jung Lee we'll we'll figure
out what the best because you know it's
like you create the disease so you can
create the Cure so why didn't that phone
call ever take place
I remember seeing that video of factor
Dr fauci being questioned by Iran Paul
and he is shaking and that was crazy
people noticed and they like zoomed in
on his hand completely and entirely
wrong and then it turns out that it was
all true we got leaked documents and
more and more information keeps coming
out I don't understand how fauci's not
already under yeah he said they were not
funding gain of reasons
you actually look at the first finding
of drastic in these documents the first
finding of it was so keep in mind I
mentioned that
um there was that New York Times article
from 2017 that talked about the return
of gain of function funding however this
was 2018. so the question is if gain of
function research has been turned back
on by Francis Collins who's the director
of the NIH he's found she's boss is
Collins
um so why are they going to DARPA if
it's been turned on at NIH here's the
rub
NIH instituted something called I
believe it's the PC3 framework by and
law by in which they were going to and
Dr airbright is part of this at Rutgers
that you are supposed to submit it to
this group essentially to get signed off
to say is this going to create a lethal
virus is this something that does
constitute dangerous gain of function so
dashak knows that and the Wuhan
Institute knows that and so they just
tweak it enough so they can argue or
what not even
that framework is only under NIH so they
say well if we go to these guys we can't
tell them all the stuff we really want
to do but if we go to DARPA maybe we can
get some funding and they don't have
that framework but at least goes and
says Common Sense we're not going to do
this guys I I have a feeling they were
trying to circumvent the system if you
look at the the amount of data and
evidence that's been coming out
implicating fauci we're just like a
month away from like a video of fauci
holding a phone and like with Peter
dashak at the one lab doing a selfie and
he's like hey what's up guys we're doing
gain of function research on back
chronoviruses and we're going to
increase human transistibility and then
he high fives and then that video comes
out and Rand Paul is like explain this
video that you took you a wrong brand
that was just us in a lab doing
modifications to chimeric viruses that
would make them enter humans more easily
so it's not gain of function research so
go back to it right look at what fauci's
done in the past because he had that
huge very public flip-flop on mask
wearing right early on he says don't do
it then later he says I had to say that
at the time because we had to shore up
the mesk supply for doctors and for
Frontline healthcare workers but now
that that time has passed the supply
chain is working we are going to open it
for everybody else so I had to say it at
the time and it was for the right
reasons that's exactly what he'll do
he'll say I had to say that at the time
but gain a function of course we were
doing gain of function and we had to do
well I don't think he'll ever do that
because I would be admitting to lying to
Congress which is perjury and that's
that's actually something where he's got
himself in a little bit of a trap that's
why he was shaken let me just say it
then get a pardoned by Biden yeah the
pardon power of the presidency is a
plenary power which means it's absolute
it cannot be overturned by it cannot be
overturned by a a proceeding president
so like like Trump can't come in and
overturn one of Obama's pardons right
and interestingly enough it can't even
be over it can't be overturned by
Congress but the Supreme Court it can't
even be overturned by yourself so if you
are president and you pardon someone
that's it they're done and you can
pardon for more than just what they've
been convicted of right so this is this
the idea of a blanket pardon and that's
actually never been challenged so
General uh Gerald Ford does this
famously for Nixon
um after in the after the events of
Watergate and he does this sort of like
blanket pardon blanket amnesty for
Watergate and essentially just nobody
decide the Congress said fine whatever
we're not going to challenge this but it
so that is sort of the leading theory
that you can give someone a blanket
pardon but it's not actually been
completely tested it's just that no
one's ever gone down that road thanks
for checking out this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast if you want to see
the full show come back to this channel
youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time